what is going on everybody and welcome
to a bit of a live
centex tinker's episode in one of our
previous videos i showed the
jarvis um just some of the jarvis
capabilities one of those capabilities
is uh transcription or
speech to text and one of the things i'm
curious about
is using their speech to text as
transcriptions
to train a text-to-speech model now you
can do text-to-speech with jarvis but
or any other model but the thing that
you need
is um audio files with their matching
transcriptions and
honestly one of the things that is the
most annoying uh
thing to do that i've ever like built a
data set for is
transcribing audio files it is the
freaking worst thing you can do
so and you can't trust anybody else to
do it for you right you can't like pay
someone to do it because if they do it
wrong
or not right the results are not going
to be good it has to be perfect so
so um so one of the things i was curious
about is using their transcriptions
here the like automated transcriptions
uh to see if that works so if you
haven't seen that
jarvis video real quick let me just show
python3
transcribe mic and then the server this
could be localhost but instead i'm going
to be oops
i'm going to be using um the dgx station
over there so dgx a100
omg 551 and what you get here is a
live transcription of the microphone
so what i want to do is take these
transcriptions and save them along with
the paired audio file
and that like spam there i don't know
what causes that spam that's so annoying
though
anyway um that won't be relevant
uh to what we're doing anyways uh so
instead of transcribing live with the
microphone we're going to do the
transcribed file
and we pull that over real quick and
that's
this now uh basically
we'll just kind of i guess take this
this is going to be very much a
hack job there will be i'm sure many
ways to improve whatever
it is that i come up with here but this
will just kind of be the first rendition
of
an attempt so what we need to do at the
end of the day is we want to have
recordings they need to be
i don't know like let's say 3 to 10
seconds of length like the lj speech
data set is
um so we need many of these wave
audio files paired with those we want to
have the transcription so we'll probably
have a transcription file
that literally set has file name and
then probably be
tab separated i think would be the best
um
tab separated and then the actual
transcription new line
next thing so that's kind of what i want
to have and
um we're just going to piece it together
now
um and so this this could get ugly it
could get very ugly but uh you guys will
witness you will witness
okay so um we'll just uh
rename any old file we'll call this uh
uh i don't know transcribe i don't want
to call it transcriber i don't know what
do you want to call this
s data set create i guess
okay so i think probably the go away
the first order of business i want to do
uh let's go ahead and fit this
where i want on screen so it's of proper
size and i'll fix the text as well here
in a second
um i think we're going to kind of have
to piecemeal
a lot of this together
and so i'm going to actually clear this
out for now we're probably going to wind
up copying and pasting
most of what was just there um
and i think what i'll actually do
so there's a couple of things so i have
done this process before one of the
times daniel actually helped
and rather than you know recording the
files one by one
we would we were downloading my youtube
files
and then i was like manually
transcribing and
kind of running through sort of like a
cli sort of program
so i like some of that so what i'd like
to be able to do is like press
keys so press a key to record uh record
look at the transcription is it good if
it is good
go ahead and save it uh and then and
then move on from there
so that's kind of like the the target of
what i want uh
to happen here so the first order of
business
is getting key presses um
in uh where is my
browser uh in ubuntu so
this will probably this is something
that's likely to vary from
from operating system to operating
system so um
uh let's see
a lot oops live keep presses
python ubuntu
uh python bluetooth direct key pro i
don't know that i want that i don't
how to detect key presses um
live key press let's look at this one
i have to accept
hmm
pip install keyboard while true
try
python has a keyboard module well we can
try that out let's see what that is
so um
bring this up uh pip3
uh let me make sure this is python 3.8
real quick yeah
pip3 install
keyboard
apparently i already have keyboard okay
i guess we've used it at some point
um maybe i don't know when i would have
used keyboard presses on here
um import keyboard so then the code
looks like
this apparently while true if keyboard
you pressed
a key if the q key is pressed you
pressed a key okay
i'm not sure on linux but oh requires
root on linux
i mean we go we probably could use root
um i'm not really sure i like to use i'd
want to do that for my file but
uh let me open up
open in terminal i think i had one
somewhere i don't know what i did with
it
oh is it this one yeah it's that one
i'll just close that out
so python3
and then we'll do tts
create
oh python3 tts data set create
wow true except
if user presses
try
so it try i don't know why that would
break why did that break
so maybe we do need this pseudo i have
no idea
what
ah okay this doesn't appear to be
working out for us very well
[Laughter]
okay um back to the drawing board
uh not sure why that's not working
pip install python i don't have no idea
um
live key press recognition python
why can't i spell ubuntu
wow i'm already a fan of that for the
simpler
version of colorama red on blue
bold wow have we just stumbled upon
something wonderful
what are the odds that it works i'm not
sure
uh pip 3 install
curtsies
wow almost looks like it might just work
uh now i gotta figure out what what the
heck page were we just on okay
so interesting so first i want to
yoink this see if that actually does
what it's supposed to i keep losing my
terminal
this is painful is it this one
yeah okay so let's see
um iphone 3 tts
okay okay we are off to a good start so
that does
appear to be accepting key presses live
i like it i like it let's break
fantastic let's keep keep the good
things coming
and um okay actually so
i think what i'll do here is copy pasta
this just to save it as a very basic
key uh live key presses
we'll just call it that uh the other
thing
that could be useful that i just
personally want to save
is where the heck was that this
window
full screen window i'm not sure what
that's about
uh i don't know enough about this kind
of stuff so
let's just see what happens we'll call
we'll just run the exact same file i
want to see beautiful colors
i really do no i thought it was going to
work this prints
normally not too strong
so that was our yellow so that part
worked where's that print
not to okay so i didn't even want the
alternative screen anyways did you
actually pop up
some alternative screen print yellow
where did that come from
i really like uh this wrapping
is it really that simple
what have we been running this with
pseudo the whole time oh i'm not sure
how we got stuck on that actually
wow i'm actually kind of excited
about a way easier version of colorama
[Laughter]
wow that's darn simple i'm i'm taking
that too that's a nice little find
i like it uh full screen window i don't
really think i care for that
uh so now i'm just curious so i just
need to take
probably this to get that functionality
is that accurate
whoo i like it i like it that puts a big
smile on my face
uh let's see tts dataset create yeah so
actually i think i might save that too
um so the live key presses let me just
pull this up real quick
where are you
yes um
i think i'll go ahead and take this
paste
and then for e and input generator
wrapper e
uh let's just do a quick test so let's
say
if uh
equals one
uh then
okay so if i come over here now
uh python three live key presses
really interesting uh
okay live key presses by one
cool okay just turn it to string so yeah
so one
records otherwise you know maybe you'll
do something else
but essentially you want to be able to
press a key get it to start recording
and then go from there so looks good i
like it i like it
it's i'm i think the most exciting thing
is this discovery of an easier
colorama i'm confident they're using
colorama in the background but
yeah this was a sort of a thing that i
kind of wanted to make for myself a long
time ago i don't think
as far as i know you can't do it that
easily with colorama
um okay so okay so we have the input now
we just need to actually record to a wav
file
so now that we've had a lot of fun
tinkering with those things
um okay so what we want to
do let's see where is our here it is
okay so um
record to wave file
uh and then we're gonna try to use pi
audio because i think we're using pi
audio with the transcribed stuff
so if i transcribe file
oh actually no it doesn't i guess it's
the transcribed mic
is that the one that uses the pi audio
yeah the transcribe mic is the one that
uses pi audio but at least i
i'm fairly confident pi audio will get
the job done for us
so uh record to wave file pi audio
um i'm not really sure we need
for iron range yeah i don't i don't want
i don't want it to be a top well
actually
we really but maybe we do want this we
would just record
um i'm not sure i like that one
wow that's like an exact replica of what
we just looked at
okay here's a record
wow these are all like copies of each
other
come on guys
[Laughter]
uh okay i think i think if you're gonna
like strictly just post a how-to
you can't just copy someone else's code
and then host it
uh okay wow none of these are what i
want i want to record
let's see record microphone
microphone i mean all we could use those
i just was hoping for a
a more easy way to break it than to have
like to tell it hey i want a static
i mean we could probably do it ourselves
what's what you got going on here bud
roy tutz roy congratulations on having
the first
the first uh unique-ish um
version okay so let's go ahead and make
a new
a new uh pasta
uh record mic
uh example and
uh tt well yeah
i guess we'll keep it there um now what
i want to do
is take all of this copy
paste so what's he doing here so chunk
that's quite the chunk okay um two
channels that's fine
rate is a pretty high rate i'm
it's easier to down sample i suppose so
if i want to down sample to like
2250 or something we can do that
[Music]
how is he well true yeah
roy is my kind of guy i love this
this is funny so basically this will
record into
until you control c
love it i love it shouts out to roy tutz
was it roy tutz.com what was that
website
roytz.com awesome
love it so okay so let us
now let's make sure it works
i take back the shouts out until we find
out if it actually works
python3 uh what was that record mic
example start recording so i guess this
is a quick
test and control c results written to
output dot
wav it's got some data there
start recording so i guess this is a
quick test
and yep cool
okay so that works awesome
so now that that is working um
let's see um we really just need to
combine the two
and then transcribe it so okay
so now uh we got the record mic example
so essentially what i want to do i'm
going to have to make this a little
smaller
this is where the hack job comes in this
is where all the mental energy is
expended
so what i want to do this is when also
multiple monitors helps a lot so it's
going to be hard for me to make sure
this is all in one screen but i'll do my
best
so probably the first thing i would
actually do is start butchering this
file so i'm going to actually copy this
dts um
i'm going to keep this here just because
i want this for my note
uh maybe we'll just
do it a little more pretty like and
we'll say green
beginning now you guys get some true
insight into the development nature
of myself and you can see i am very
messy
so uh okay so so record
and then all we want to do probably is
we'd like to rather than ctrl c
out of the recording we'd like to pre
have a key press get us
in or out so with with
okay four e okay we're going to do this
sometimes okay i'm gonna
copy that come over here
frames wow true
how is this um sorry
i have name with 4e and
input generator so it's almost
we almost need to still break out of
this huh
i'm not sure how to handle for this uh
because when we go to record
we're going to
i'm already lost we're going to need to
we need some way of breaking the
recording i don't think this will work
very well like i don't
think with
because even in this case we're going to
have to break
although i guess we could issue it we
could issue a break
recording uh
so what if we say
uh one again stopping so we press
one well eventually we'll pl press one
to record but right now i just wanna see
can we actually
stop it with a one when we go to record
stopping
if that blah blah uh four
break that would break us out of the for
loop
let's go ahead and try that and just see
we'll see what happens
i'm not very good at predicting at this
point uh tts data set create
whoops name input not defined uh with in
what
okay we just need to import this come
back up here
okay we'll try that one more time this
text is probably way too small
hopefully that's a little better for
y'all start recording
please tell me that worked please tell
me this works
uh it just feels so good uh-oh
no i don't think this is working
why wouldn't that work why wouldn't that
work
someone tell me why that's not working
um
let's try it one more time dang it oh so
excited
i really thought we were onto something
and we're not
okay results written what do we got
still this like it's like this tiny 44
bytes file
it was just probably just baseline file
dang it
i was on such a high uh
what are we gonna do about that
and what would cause that why would that
be
so um try with
so it doesn't stop immediately so this
clearly runs runs runs runs runs
the break actually works for us
um
man what a bummer uh i'm gonna do this
but i don't
this is not going to solve the problem i
don't think but if it does i guess i'll
laugh at myself so now nothing now will
try to break
and it's a different size but not big
enough for what
yeah it's almost like it just saved like
the one frame
hmm
that's so close to realizing my dreams
for e so i'm just going to continue
trying to figure out what the heck
happened here
uh with input okay
ah so
with input as input generator and then
the only reason why that loops is
because we're just iterating through
this generator makes sense
um what if we this will be my last
attempt and then i'll probably have to
i don't even know maybe
we'll stick with the rob tuts or roy
tuts
roy tutz we might have to stick with
roy's method of breaking the recording
i don't like it but sometimes you know
i'm sure somebody will come up with a
better one after they see this but
uh let's try one more time record record
record
and break let's see what happens
wow so that records it does record
so let's check it but i'm yep
so at some point when so
while true works for e and input
generator
okay i wish i understood why this was
such a problem for e
input generator
i guess because so so we have the input
generator
and but we get stuck in the generator
but why we can't be
while we're stuck in the generator
running some more code i don't
understand
uh
this is this is gonna be disgusting i
just
i just i can't help myself i just can't
help myself
um for e
i don't even know what e would be but
i'm assuming it's just gonna be a list
of possibly keys that are pressed i
don't know
um coming back
i'm just super curious if this works uh
please
oh wait start recording one said
recording i'm not sure what's going on
i have n i have no idea what the heck
just happened but uh what i can say is
our file is too small
it could be something super obvious i'm
just being a goon
but uh i don't think this is gonna work
out i think we're gonna have to stick
with roy tutz
uh and his control c
i don't like it i don't like it but this
could be something i can
possibly fix later so if you have an
idea on what the heck is the deal there
let me know let's go make sure this
saves
cool it does all right so and i'm just
basing this off of the size of the file
by the way
so now that we've done that um
thanks to our our friend at roy tutz um
i wish we could not have to control c
because i can already imagine that's
going to be very annoying but
um i'll hunt for another solution there
so now that we've got that far what
we're going to do
now is
well i guess we would just begin editing
down here so we'll record the file
and basically the thing will start and
let's see this is live key presses
i wonder if we'll be able to loop within
this though
i'm not really sure
okay with input
i think we'll be fine because we just
need to
exit that at some point and a break does
seem to exit it for some reason we're
unable to record while we are inside of
this
and maybe that has i don't know what
i don't know i don't know it doesn't
make any sense to me
i'm sure super obvious to somebody um
okay so
uh if string e we're gonna be pressing c
already so my finger will be like over
there it's gonna be very tedious moving
back and forth so i'm gonna go ahead and
stick with c
so if the if c is pressed then we will
record we'll run
record to file recording uh
and then i don't know
uh press control plus c to
stop recording i'm gonna need notes
that's for sure
okay let's see
are we no why are we saying that already
press oh oh
up here okay we'll fix that in a second
oh i was pressing one okay
this is a mess okay okay we're gonna
control c
please have a file size done recording
start recording done recording why are
you not saving or what
we're still are we still in this loop
i guess we are
see how come i can break out of that
loop and then record and then
it this draws me nuts um
done recording so where is this here
and then now we're back into this so
after record file okay print
green
saved file press
c to record again
that might already work it does already
work
okay so actually we get into the loop
pretty quickly
let's break and let's make sure that
recording works but it has a proper size
so let's see
okay okay we are making um
some progress here i'm getting happy
uh all right uh i think actually
probably pretty soon i'll probably
stop this one and chunk into another
video
um i'm trying to think if there's
anything major i want to fix
before we do that i i once again will
reiterate
i am super stoked about these colors i
just i literally just stumbled upon that
and
that's going to change everything for me
i'm going to use the heck out of that
library
it's kind of like when i discovered the
tq tqdm
i just use it everywhere now okay um
let's see recording
saved file press c to record again so
let's talk i think i will probably just
stop it here so let's talk about
what we need to do next uh
from here we want to take
essentially we want to take that output
file and in fact one of the things i
usually do
i'll just do it here um there's a few
things that we'll smooth out for sure
but once we have um like once we
have output.web we
want to see the transcription so we want
to actually once we have the output.wav
file
we're going to run that through the
transcribe file
file from jarvis we'll get the
transcription we'll just like pop the
transcription up on c
on the screen uh you know then we'll
have like
press probably c to accept it
or some other key to
um
skip probably so press another key to
skip um
we also
we also should have a check for
the file length or rather uh duration
um so i think we want to probably cap
duration at 10 seconds i think that's
the lj speech data set and all of the
uh text-to-speech models will
likely have some sort of constraint like
that or could
so we just we just wouldn't want to
handicap ourselves uh
and get into trouble with too long of
files
so i think i think that's pretty good
hopefully um
in at the next tackle of this we can we
can get these things
done um and like i said if anybody has
an idea
for how i can because c versus control c
is not like the end of the world but
that's kind of tedious
uh as funny as that sounds but it's
gonna be
you know you're gonna be recording for
like hours and you're gonna be doing
or like an hour or you know in total
you're gonna have like hours of
recording
and stretch even just stretching those
fingers that long like control c
controls
it will get annoying whereas if you just
had to use your index finger it would
just be so much nicer
um other than that this is actually off
to a pretty good start
so then once we uh if we like the file
if the file is good move to some data
directory
and save file name plus
transcription to transcription
dot some sort of likely tsv tab
separated file
um tsv tab separated i guess variables
anyway um yeah cool
i think that's good hope you guys
enjoyed uh watching me
uh tinker uh and uh this is fairly
realistic to a lot of the pro
or the uh uh programs i attempt to build
or you know
projects that i start working on um
we're just trying to find a way to do
something so like in this case
um yeah it's like what let's see let's
get these
uh things in while we're thinking about
it anyways so
uh like the recording
came from roy tutz and then the key
press stuff
is from curtsy's i'm not sure we
actually need to
assign any credit to curtsy's uh beyond
that
uh but for the recording stuff uh
let's see we'll take this
pasta and
pasta
yeah that's good enough um
cool so all right
good enough like i said if you can think
of a way for me to have a key press
and record at the same time or if you
know why doesn't the recording work
um while it's checking while it's going
through that generator
like why not i i don't know why that's
unacceptable
um someone educate me uh otherwise i
will see you guys
in the next video
you